Speaker 1: Donald Trump has opened a 36
point lead over Ron DeSantis in a new poll.
These are stunning numbers, 58 to 22. 58 to
22. Trump is leading DeSantis in a new poll,
an even bigger lead than what we have seen
recently. CBS News YouGov poll of 2300 voters.
I am continuing to tell you that
we can look at all aspects of this,
but unless something seriously changes, unless
something really changes, I don't see a path
for anyone other than Trump to win that Republican
nomination, including DeSantis Desanctis, Dissent,
pneumonias, whatever you want to call the guy. He
doesn't have a path to the 50% he needs unless he
can take support from Donald Trump. When you're at
58% as Trump is, you don't need any more voters.
You've already got what you need. Now, of course,
if you only have it in certain states and not
others and the timing of the primaries. There's
this these narrow, narrow, narrow scenarios. But
much like I was honest with you, in the 2020
Democratic primary, when I saw that it wasn't
looking like Bernie had a path and many people
got mad at me. It's not looking mathematically
like DeSantis has a path unless something happens
with Trump, either. Some self-inflicted error,
multiple arrests that take him off the campaign
trail, and definitely something like that. Trump
already has enough Republican support to win
the nomination without convincing a single
additional voter. So we will see where things
look in a month as we will be closer to when,
I guess the Sanders would be announcing if
he plans to. But as of right now, it's hard
to imagine what's going to get in Trump's way
of being the Republican nominee once again.